wir sprechen nun mit dem
allgemeinmediziner dr assmann dr assmann
vielen dank dass sie sich für uns zeit
nehmen
wie haben sie die nachricht erfahren
dass wir nun doch früher impfen können
als ursprünglich vorgesehen
ja einfach ein wort geil endlich endlich
können wir diesen kleinen erstmal
richtig feuer machen
da freue ich mich die ganze zeit drauf
man muss auch so sagen dass wir keinen
notfall zulassung haben mit diesem stoff
sondern eine beschleunigte zulassung ist
einen noch höheren sicherheitsstandard
gewährleistet das spricht an sich
nochmal für den impfstoff doch da ist
man ab zu welchen zeiten rechnen sie
damit dass die hausärzte das impfen mit
übernehmen können
ich hoffe dass es ende frühling anfang
sommer starten kann weil wenn wir den
impfstoff bekommen und zwar heute von
moderner ja weil sechs bis acht grad im
kühlschrank etwa sechs wochen haltbar
ist dann können wir denn genauso
verhalten wie im stoff und wenn sie
überlegen ist die kapazität hätten eine
art von vier hat man ja von vier monaten
bis zu 20 millionen einheiten zu
verhelfen sehen sie was für eine chance
dahinter versteht dass wir bis ende
september diesen bios den garaus machen
könnte wenn wir den song selber regeln
18 25 millionen impfungen ja immer
praktisch neben der normalen
praxisbetrieb also da sehen sie was für
kapazitäten wir haben dafür ist
natürlich auch wichtig dass möglichst
viele menschen sich auch impfen lassen
wollen deswegen wollen wir natürlich
auch die angst etwas nehmen und wollen
von ihnen als mädchens experten wissen
können sie diese impfung guten herzens
empfehlen ohne ja bedenken da kann ich
sie beruhigen der auszeit immer ein
gutes herz und er kann natürlich
wirklich diesen impfstoff empfehlen
deswegen weil er müssen sehen die eine
gruppe ist 30 30.000 leute sind da
kontrolliert und in der anderen mit dem
moderner im stoff etwa 40.000 zusammen
schon 70.000 menschen an diesem stoff
schon bekommen
große nebenwirkungen sind nicht bekannt
man muss aber sagen natürlich ist
langzeit nebenwirkungen
also da rede ich jetzt von fünf bis zehn
jahren natürlich einfach kann man
einfach kunden dieses langen zeitraums
natürlich noch nicht vorhersehen
man muss aber sagen was wäre die was
wäre die alternative
die alternative ein lockdown für drei
vier jahren konsequent durch oder die
alten handels isolieren und so weiter so
habe ich ganz große hoffnungen in diesen
impfstoff in diesen infektionen um ihre
hausärzte sind in der lage und können
das auch tatsächlich zu unterstützen
wir sind jetzt schon werden wir das
zentrum bei uns im kreis mit besetzen
und wie gesagt die bereitschaft dafür
ist enorm und die so auch gerade gesagt
dass wir hoffen dass mit dieser impfung
wie dem bios den garaus machen können
aber gibt es auch noch die befürchtung
dass der impfstoff am ende vielleicht
doch gar nicht wirkt weil er eben noch
nicht lange genug getestet wurde
also da kann ich so ein bisschen
beruhigen und zwar der iss getestet
worden ja bald weiß ich beziehungsweise
in dem anderen 42.000 menschen und man
hat festgestellt dass etwa 90 bis 95
prozent der impflinge antikörper
gebildet haben gegen diesen virus und
damit also auch wirksame eine wirksame
impfung ist jetzt muss man dazu noch
sagen dass wenn sie sehen dass der
normale grippeschutzimpfung etwa nur
eine durchschlagskraft von 60 bis 70
prozent haben haben wir mit diesem stoff
wirklich eine gute chance da dem virus
wirklich mal beine zu machen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren